this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm going to I'm going to take you on to
world wind tours of the garden one that
shows the weaknesses of the garden and
one that I hope shows our strengths
I'll then try to slow down and talk a
little bit about the context about of
this garden both in the past and today
and the last part I hope that Don Rocco
will appreciate it the last part is of
my presentation will be about our
attempts to to respect the past and
prepare the future as to say how how do
we cultivate this space how do we
cultivate a historical garden and why do
we do it that way
what is it the same as in the past or
not in some sense it's public garden
management so here's for a whirlwind
tour of the garden first with its
weaknesses then when it's with its
strengths first weakness is when you
work in the garden that's what you see
if you walk up the ramp that's what you
see if you walk down the steps on the
other side that's what you see if you go
look up that's what you see above the
peach trees if you keep walking you go
through a door and you see a wall
without trees that seems to be falling
well let's say just unkempt if we go to
the back of the garden you start seeing
the tops of the garden the tops of the
walls are not so good either the bottoms
of the walls neither and that's not good
English but I'll survive the walls are
separating when we're against the trees
we haven't taken off the ferns or the
mosses you're at the bottom of the wall
sometimes you're not quite sure you
should walk through the door if you look
up you understand why the bottom of the
door is not working if you walk to the
very back you notice I shouldn't point
this out but I'm going to anyway we
still have asbestos in the garden it's
covered by moss though
but we have will have to get rid of it
one day this is what our garages look
like we haven't replaced all the windows
the car model is from the 1970s if you
try to leave the garden you start to see
there were some reparations but some of
the edges are not all that good and this
is what's left of our last greenhouse
from the 19th century the others have
were destroyed
sometimes walls actually fall down this
was a year ago this is the same wall
from the other direction this is what it
looks like today we're getting there
it's actually a type of youth build
program that we're going to rebuild the
wall this summer concretely that means I
didn't spend any money to do it because
the entire garden which is I have to
remember this 24 acres 9.4 hector's is
we I manage it with 40,000 euros not
counting salaries but the total
investment of how to say functioning
money is 40,000 euros so let's say
$50,000 for 24 acres so and I've
actually thought to mention a another
another big problem
I forgot I mentioned something else
this presentation is rather general and
for those of you who would be interested
in in a history of plant selection
fruits of becquer's you have to stay for
Soho afterwards I just wanted to mention
that and I also want to mention that I
wasn't an undergraduate and that when I
was an undergraduate here I never
imagined I'd be coming back for a second
time to give a talk here
I'd have to mention that the biggest
problem is actually not all what I just
showed you the biggest problem is this
the biggest problem we have in this
garden is drainage it was built on an
old swamp and they put in a massive
drainage system in the 17th century it
hasn't been properly kept up and so
we're faced with some real questions of
route asphyxiation and
other difficulties of that type so
that's what those are the problems but
you'll notice that I use this as a
punctuation that's how I change from one
self up to another one of our strengths
so let's do another world wind tour of
the garden but this time a little bit
better I'm gonna start in an early
winter morning and we're gonna go to a
late fall afternoon so if I go towards
the Sun I find myself in the alleyways
where in a regular garden create at the
end of the 17th century this whole
system of perspectives of straight lines
but that aren't all that controlling if
I go forward I go towards spring for me
it's the most anxious ridden part of the
year I think it is for any fruit grower
it's not the moment where I'm working
the most but it's the moment where I
sleep less live least if I go through
the door and I take a right I go towards
summer it's the Kings gate and leave in
the back the Kings gate is the last
original gate this gate is the last
original gate of the palace of F sight
we're gonna see more general later
you'll see this is still the whirlwind
tour if I go around the Central Basin
and I look the other way I see the
Cathedral next door which is younger
than the garden the Cathedral dates from
1740 to the garden date in 1670 a tours
begun to be constructed in 1678 and when
and generally when I look at this church
the first thing I want to do and the
only thing I really want to do in it is
go to the top that's what the garden
looked like when I arrived about 10
years ago you'll see a lot of dirt if
you look at more or less the same time
of year a few years later it's changed
it's gotten there's a lot more grass a
lot less dirt visible a lot less
herbicide use we're going to talk about
that if we go towards autumn you can see
some of our fruit tree shapes some of
our cabbage patches that if you look at
more closely this is a variety of the
19th
middle 19th century
Peartree all the varieties middle 19th
century the actual tree is about hundred
and forty years old a five tiered flat
this buddy a tree you have 68 different
fruit tree shapes in the garden this is
going towards the autumn the colors
change and this is the Setting Sun
behind the creator of the garden whose
name was almighty second-team
punctuation those are my two world wind
tours now let's try to get a bit more
specific and try to give a context tried
to understand the old uses and the new
uses of this garden so this is all of
that sigh this is the Palace and the
kitchen garden is right here but close
and you see the Grand Canal a closer
look that was a early 18th century map
this is a middle 19th century matte just
because it has a nicer close-up and
nicer colors you can see the kitchen
garden better you can see the extent of
the palace you should realize just this
is the only thing that's really knew
about that well this is the mean of me
to say the only thing that's really knew
about this I basically is that when you
go when you walk this you've walked 600
meters so you've walked not quite half a
mile but that's a single facade the
basic innovation of their site is its
size after that there are some technical
innovations about how to make flat glass
how to drain but basic thing about now
site is just its size so it ends up with
a kitchen garden which isn't an acre or
two acres but 24 acres what does it look
like today that's what it looks like
today an aerial view from a few years
ago you can see the size of the palace
you can see the real hartley which has
approximately 2,500 potted large potted
plants that go in and out and you have
the kitchen garden here with the school
that's in the garden along the
building's because today it's a school
we'll get to that this just just to try
to point out how the garden changes this
is a mid 18th century it's upside down
but you'll see why this is a mid 18th
century map this is a mid 19th century
map the big difference is that aren't
all that obvious ok
here you have three Gardens it's going
to become one or two here you have
diagonal walls they will disappear you
have eleven gardens here we still call
them the eleven gardens but there's only
five because some of the walls got taken
out okay there are other differences but
basically the shape has stayed the same
the big difference you can see here is
the number of glass houses in the
midnight in the mid 18th century there
was lots of glass glass jars glass bells
and I call them in English Josh you say
close I should I should have known that
and lots of hot beds but there weren't
much there weren't many green houses
actually I think you see one on the on
the image the only green house that
existed at the time was right here and
in French the word for green house is
sad
ser re and everyone thinks that that's a
green house originally a SAN has a place
where you Jose which means that you or
you reorganize note you store things and
this is the same but it's not a green
house it's where everything was stopped
so this why this map why is it important
although it's upside-down because in
1874 which is one mid 19th century I
exaggerate second half is in 1874 a
school was created in the garden and
since 1874 the kitchen garden is no
longer under the administration of the
palace so it's been hundred and forty
years now that this garden is separate
from the palace always in a school when
it was first created it was the national
school for French horticulture today it
is the
national school for landscape
architecture this is the map we show
today that we give to our visitors the
idea is you come in over here this is
the entrance today although the historic
entrance is here you come in here the
departure is always here for the visits
but two three four and we take you
around the garden today it's no longer
the landscape horticulture school
it's the landscape architecture school
and the logo for the school the national
school of super yellow means higher
education it doesn't mean the superior
to others it simply means that it's it's
not elementary or secondary school after
secondary Couture comes to value
universities are super yeah ok so it's
part of the university system but the
logo for the school is a my English is
terrible
it's a stylized version of the of the
central square of the kitchen-garden and
that for me is very important because
it's the question of how do you go from
garden to landscape and the pedagogical
how to say the the educational
progression of the students in the
landscape architecture school go from a
first-year about garden creating gardens
to a second year about larger urban
spaces or larger spaces and the third
year working on coastal or
railroad tracks that that that truly
across entire landscapes so the hot the
idea is to go from small to large from
microcosm microcosm to macrocosm the
school is present in the garden but you
do have to understand or realize that
there was some kind of fundamental
contradiction between a historical
garden and a landscape architecture
school they think of themselves as
conceptor as artists creators often at
least in France I'm not sure for here
they're not gardeners and on the other
hand does a historic garden that tries
to that communicates with them but in
which eventually they come and see
things occasionally here they discover
what soil is and three days a year they
actually work in the garden this is a
rare picture this is three days a year
okay actually it's three days a year the
first year two days a year the second
year one day or the third year so one of
the main projects in terms of restoring
this garden and I do like landscape
architects don't get me wrong I just
want them to be more aware that once
they've created something you have to
manage it there's a landscape architect
in France so you might have heard of who
his name is Giacomo who had a phrase one
day that I really liked
he said landscape architect's shouldn't
be paid until 10 years after they've
given their project
but I don't think landscape architects
would agree and I understand that they
wouldn't agree so what how can we make
these things work together well if I try
to zoom simply on this picture I see
this behind it and the project to try to
make this school work together work with
the garden together is in that building
and those two buildings to take some of
the spaces that are in them and use them
to create a residency for international
landscape architect's where they both
will be interested in what the and
teaching with the students of the school
and also in working with the garden the
ideas that they come and we find a space
within the garden to work with them try
to do the two together so we're in the
process of actually raising money for
this and we've raised not that much but
some and we will start we're looking for
essentially three million euros and
we've already raised over half of it so
we're getting there it's not a we're
well on the way when we'll start
construction will start redoing because
you don't see it very well in this
picture but we'll start redoing some of
the problems on the windows and at the
end of the summer and installing some of
the spaces where all people you will
already be receiving some international
artists this fall that's the aerial view
and as usual my punctuation because all
this is very important but what's most
important to me is not just the students
it's the gardener's
because the space doesn't exist without
carcass without a you know the a garden
doesn't exist unless to our gardeners
you can have a forest you can have
spaces without card nurse but you can't
have a garden without gardener and and
what they do when I arrived in the
garden 2004 both these men were working
Jack and Paul suave and in 2007-2008
they retired both of them and they have
to be replaced well the idea was to
replace them before they left so that
there would be some transmission and
they were placed essentially by these
two young men who've grown a bit older
since this picture to do the same things
that were being done before so we have
68 different fruit tree shape this is
one that's particular has each one has a
name by the way and they're actually
there's that we have a list of over 250
that we would like to make but gotta
keep all of them going this is one that
takes a good 25 years to make it's
called a vanity see so that's an early
20th century picture this is an early
21st century picture
this is a fruit variety from the middle
of the 17th century one of the ones that
was originally cultivated by black can
see he's a creator of the garden and
that we still have in the garden today
this is a and that was that that this is
a mid 18th century print but this is a
17th century pear that we still have in
the garden today and that I chose to
show with our 450 different historic
well not just historical 450 different
fruit variety if I go to vegetables the
person who is now responsible generally
responsible what I call the the captain
is 1515 do fool I always like I don't do
my job properly if I don't talk about
the gardener's they're the ones who are
outside when it's cold not me I'm in
here with you I hope to come back here
with this summer with her we'll see if
it works or not somehow rather I'm in
the position of a coach I try to give a
perspective I try to create a plan I try
to make sure that they can work but
she's one who gets the work done
what do they do well with she's
particularly on vegetables but she also
takes care of the fruit this is the the
vegetable team in their different areas
of predilection whether it be herbs
greater production or tropical plants
for dev even we use old catalogs not so
much to recreate but to find to have
ideas about what worked then what works
now so in 1909 among the most popular
tomato fruits order this one here which
one the left Wow Wow
there it is five what at the home I'll
get it and we still have it in the
garden now we have generally we don't
every year I was talking to mr.
Christopher Dunn this morning about how
he functions with the vegetable garden
and we do much the same thing actually
we can't do everything every year it's
not possible so we have about we try to
have a selection of between 300 and 400
vegetable varieties every year and the
idea is to have some that what we are
what we call collection we try them out
and some that we are producing and
you'll see why I talk about that in just
a moment because we sell everything we
Purdue forgot where I was so we have
some in collections I mean production
anywhere between 300 and 400 varieties
every year every two years we try to
choose one that we get to know better so
we will do one year eighty tomato
varieties but generally we do between 25
and 30 we do the same thing for example
for for beings this is a late 18th
century drawing we have beans just want
to remind you that it was a tropical
plant at one point we did one year we
have had over 100 varieties of beans and
everybody thinks that these are in terms
of people come to visit the garden yes
they're also for the gardener's because
for them to know about beans they have
to try them out and if we want to be
able to answer questions from our from
our visitors we have to have the
knowledge so if we only stick on the 15
or 20 bean varieties we're used to we
can't answer the questions that people
come to see us so
every year we try to take eggplant or
peppers or scallions onion we tried to
do every year try to try out as many as
we can find but generally in terms of
what we produce for regular production
we're we're about a hundred varieties
but we go up to 300 or 400 depending on
on the year we're doing but we're not
just fruits and vegetables there is a
small group one or two gardeners who
work on general uptake we have a small
you say rosary
they wrote we have a small rosary or
about 60 different varieties we have
about 800 different accents of
ornamental plants on purpose or not on
purpose they're there the older person
that was there in 2004 the younger
person who's there now we have a young
team what do they take care of well we
have this 200 long metre terrace that
has two sides of a boxwood that's what
it looks like in winter that's what it
looks like in summer that's already a
bit of work and there's box in many
other parts of the garden as well that
needs to be taken care of is there a
boxwood blight here as well I want to
tear them up anyway they smell like this
in the summer in the spring and they're
totally unproductive and they're not
existent in this garden in the 17th
century they were introduced in the 19th
and I want to replace them by herbal
aromatic herbal borders the gardener's
are in revolt against me because it's
more work and basically that's all I can
say about box
is that the reason box exists is it's
that's work from the rest I hope the
people who like box don't
disagree too much but I haven't found
another reason for box yet we have a
fruit of cedam which is in some sense
what's left over from the horticultural
school when it was there these are two
of my favorite plants in the fruit senem
we have hundreds 174 ornamental shrubs
that are stuck in a corner of the garden
that's eventos zealand seam xi which is
a such one
and with my French accent no seriously
food yet so so pond service whatever
role the orange trees are are grafted on
but it makes great yellow fruit that you
can grate or use to aromatize to home of
teasing to flavor jams and I'll talk
about that in a little while too but the
real point of all these gardeners is
this the real point of this kitchen
garden has always been to be a kitchen
garden because so far that's not what
I've shown you we produce about 40 tons
of fruit we produce about 20 25 tons of
vegetables and it all gets sold in a
small space at the entrance some people
think that's a lot I think it's very
little for 24 acres the gardeners think
it's a lot of work and I understand them
but I did a simple calculation just the
other day if I take 40 tons of fruit and
I transform about 15 into juice and gem
that only leaves me with 25 tons if I
have a 10% loss 20% loss storage if
everything else I'm down to 20 tons and
if I tried to do that over 52 weeks I
come out with only 150 kilos a week
that's not that much so 40 times is not
oh I'm I talked about jams I have a
present for Don and I have a present for
Soho but they'll have to choose how they
want to work this is our mug and this is
two of our jams to a pair of varieties
so you'll have to choose afterwards but
that's what we do that's what we do that
is you know that is how we make our
money that's how we calibrate our budget
our budget it's a public garden it owned
by the state but we have to make a
living and I think that's very important
in terms of public garden management the
idea that a garden can be productive can
be visited and can produce produce we do
everything jams we make the jams
ourselves we also dry our own peppers
our own we make our own deploy well mix
and we even have partnerships with a tea
company this is our mug we even have
partnership with a tea company where
there we have a particular apple variety
which I adore which is called and it's
called Canada I net new kind of that
bernoulli
but nobody wants to buy anymore in
France because it's wonderful cooked but
people don't cook apples anymore they
always want to eat them fresh they want
to eat them raw it's very difficult to
sell several tons of this Apple but it
has a wonderful flavor and a great aroma
we found a solution we sell it to a tea
company they extract the aroma they use
it to flavor their teas it's our biggest
seller
I'm trying to remember what I haven't
told you yet and in terms of the time
okay and once I talk about food the what
I think is probably the most important
thing people come to this garden because
it's historic garden they come there
because it's about sight they come
because Louie the 14th and there's this
image there's this there's this
trademark here you have Devi the one who
likes tropical fruits and there's also
one of our best ambassadors they come
for that reason but we want them to
leave with a better understanding of
today's contemporary stakes for fruit
and vegetable production and consumption
how does it function
I mean iíve taken groups of I used to
think this wasn't true but I've taken
groups of not so young children into the
garden and shown them the potato plant
and had them say to me where's the
potato and I've shown them pea plants
and and I've even taken adults into the
garden and showed them a spinach plot
and the person said I were the spinach
and I realized that the person could
recognize it when it was on a on a shelf
because it was separated it was only
spinach but when it was mixed in with
gallon Soga or with something else and
it was close to the ground
they couldn't recognize it so basically
when they come in the garden they come
to see historic garden we want them to
leave with a better understanding of
fruits and vegetables so that's what I'm
gonna try to do now this is Debbie
talking to a group this is what we try
to show to our groups this is an
exhibition I didn't do that we did in
2007 about fruit varieties it was
annexed we took 3 editions of a book or
70 book from 1768 was republished in the
early 19th century and we tried to put
the varieties that were in the book out
and we tried to show that the three
versions of the same book didn't
describe them the same way and that
somehow or other people should give up
on trying to give a specific name to a
variety we did an exhibition about beans
where I discovered something rather
important for me at least industrial how
to say those beans string green beans
that were bred to flower at the same
time
be harvested at the same time to stand
up to transformation into whatever are
often not good when you eat them after
transformation but when they're actually
out there and eat them fresh you can
pick them yourself they're actually
excellent
so the problem really is on the the
processing side because some of the
industrial varieties that everybody is
screaming about but they're not good
when they're in the processed food it
can be excellent when they're in the
field and that was I thought that in
terms of trying to understand how our
agricultural functions that's an
important point to say that modern
varieties are not necessarily bad they
can have some real interest too
including taste the question is how
they're used afterwards so maybe we have
to not just yell at the farmers we have
to try to educate people to cook better
we did an exhibition this was purely for
the landscape architecture students this
was my this was this is what I call
thumbing my nose we did an exhibition
about pollination because I was tired of
getting comments about landscape
architects who didn't know about plants
being allergenic and I did a
presentation in front of the Board of
Trustees of the school and I mentioned a
landscape architect who had populated a
who had planted a school yard with lots
of beech lots of birch trees and birch
trees are among the most allergenic what
I didn't know when I did this
presentation was that the president of
the work trustees was that landscape
architect but it still went over fine
because the students did learn that
plants were allergenic
how to bring people to the garden we
have we've been having our eighth or
ninth year we have a it's a school it's
a school of landscape architecture we
have a festival a modern art festival
annal in a historical garden every year
it's essentially dance it's essentially
conceptual dance in a movement in France
called
non dance and I think that's wonderful I
think it's a great example of bringing
people to a historical space to remind
them this historical space is always
about being new it's not about being old
and when it was created it was created
to be new so let's keep using it as a
space that's new every year we have a
annual Harvest Festival you can't do
without it it's the moment of the year
where we have the most amount of things
to sell and so we need a lot of people
to buy them and it's also the moment
where we can show the most diverse
things of what we do so every year first
weekend of October we try to present the
70 or 80 varieties of fruit that are
still available that we can sell at that
point and as many varieties of
vegetables this is an example and this
is where we get to how do we cultivate I
look at the hour
most people will see Louise burn which
is one of my favorite pairs on the left
and kind of you belong to one of my
favorite apples on the right I often
compare candy we belong to join of gold
as the example as the difference between
Bordeaux and California oh I got myself
into this now I can tell you why I do do
I don't usually say that one but
California wine this was worth out of
know very good for me it's big juicy
fruit right away it's wonderful it's how
do they say cut no it's uh it's explodes
an explosion and if you're used to
California Cabernet Sauvignon you drink
a ball do generally you're disappointed
it's like poison you know it's not as
big it's not drawn of gold when you
taste it it explodes in your mouth it so
it's it's a wonderful Apple you take the
country blowing the first thing you say
is oh it's an apple and then 30 seconds
later you say wait there's still a taste
there that there's a little bit of
fennel there's there's a little bit of
mint
but there's the apples strong and then
two minutes later it's still in your
nose and you're saying what what's it
still doing there that's the difference
between the California Academy and a
baldric about a canteen but that's not
what I see I'll show you what I see I
hope that some of you see it too
how many people see apples repaired on
the market with scab that's what we do
all the time and I hope that people can
get used to it
we're not organic but we do spray and
even if we do spray with non with
organic they still have to get dressed
up that way and we call it our Chernobyl
suits and how do you do that in the
public garden above and beyond I do not
know the the regular that has the rules
in the States but in our case there's
even on copper sulfate where there's a
24-hour limit before going on - how do
you do that in the public garden that's
open seven days a week and how do you do
it when you're in a public garden that
produces fruits and vegetables and next
to the trees you have strawberries and
just a copper sulfate remember right
it's 21 days before harvest what do you
do well you can say you sprayed the
trees enough to print the strawberries
so you can still bring the strawberries
to the store ethically I'm not up for it
okay how do we do it well we find
solutions one way or another our first
solutions we no longer treat the central
square where the fruit trees and the
vegetables are in the same place I have
not asked for an organic label we've
noted a 60% lowering in harvest but
we're still making it and we're gonna
probably do something that's going to
shock not you but shock the the people I
work for or the people who are
guarantees in terms of the state for the
preservation of historic monument I'd
like to tear out the pear trees and put
in plum trees slightly different shape
two arguments first of all it'll give us
a time to know how to cultivate pear
trees without treating them because for
the moment we don't know and plum trees
will only last 2025 years in his study
of shapes so it's just a time period and
the second reason is because palm tree
is we can treat them during the winter
we don't have many visitors and they are
vigorous enough to survive most attacks
until we harvest them in July
we'll see but it has been 320 240 years
now that it's been the central squares
been cultivated with pear trees and some
people take me to be a bit radical the
other choice of course is to find
solutions to fight opera that's what I
worked on when I was in here at Cornell
I spent hours in the lab trying to go
through to try to find mutant spores
well we do treat them with copper
sulfate but we do it very specifically
in specific situations and not all the
time and sometimes we even do it when
visitors are there because it's a way
for them to go and to talk to them
because in the States
if I remember right only 2% of the
population is agricultural today in
France it's not that much more it's four
there is a huge educational defeat
challenge in terms of getting people to
know where what they eat comes from it's
also when and this is items on purpose
for here gallon sub is in a North
American plant this is a sherbet also in
American North American plant or
American plant where where are the
squash in there after yet people used to
seeing that too and I've even the
gardeners happy when he finds one they
react poorly to this they react poorly
to the one before this is my favorite
way of dealing with weeds in a garden at
least in our garden I think it's
perfectly fine I think that if we did
the entire garden in black plastic
that's woven though and biodegradable
but I don't think people would
appreciate it either but this is how we
deal in a historic garden with producing
Tomatoes peppers
we do some green manure and when they
see this they don't understand when they
see this they I'm seeing a bit better
but I'm not that much more satisfied
because if we have too much Celia tested
yet then with Elia whatever
in the fall we create problems for our
honeybees because they're going to be
harvesting later they're not going to be
able to to dry out the nectar as long
and we're gonna have honey that freezes
so we have to be careful about our green
manure as well people complain when they
come to the garden and they see this I
complain to the garden when I arrived
and I saw this because that's how it was
dealt with before we're now at zero
herbicide use but we do have more grass
and I think the next three pictures are
probably what I would like to show you
most and then probably the whole
presentation was just for these three
wonderful fruit tree shapes what do we
do with our soil
this is herbicide used since 1969
that's when Jacque I showed you on the
first picture arrived he spent a year
with a hoe in his hand and he got sick
of it and he started using herbicides
the garden was coated with herbicides
almost entirely up until 2004 2005 2006
we said we have to stop we had to find
solutions that was the first idea but it
took a lot of work Geo textile the idea
was to have something clean underneath
the plant something where we could still
continue to see the tree because we're
also dealing with synthetic the solution
we have today is this one because we
found a machine for mechanical
cultivation under the trees that we
adapted from fruit from vineyard culture
we still have to mow the lawn but we
have other ideas for that where we let
them some of them flower but the basic
question is what are we doing in
historical garden how does this function
are we a professional fruit growers
searching for solutions for professional
fruit growing are we a historical garden
trying to be faithful to what the people
did 300 years ago and my answer is both
we have to find solutions to both 300
years ago they were already producing in
large quantities for the Kings table
today we have to continue producing in
large quantities 300 years ago they had
visitors today we have visitors we have
to keep those two together we both have
to take into account modern techniques
modern limits and we also have to
remember the intentions with which it
was created
and for me the right here the difference
between this oops sorry
this picture and this picture is a
difference in how we relate to our
environment in the first picture we're
producing fruits that's it we have fruit
tree shape we're producing fruit in this
picture we're managing a space and as
soon as we start managing a space that
has ideas about production we're also
producing other things we're also taking
care and this is very easy to say and
I'm sure you've heard this lots of times
but we're taking part of an ecosystem
and we're taking part of both cultivated
and wild this is one this is the largest
wild French solitary bee hook this is we
have a huge population of this middy
today polina that nobody really
understands why we have it and we have
it in the garden and I've tried to study
it a little bit and it's an interesting
conundrum we have it because we used
herbicides because it likes sandy soil
that doesn't have plant on it they want
to make its burrows to make its nest and
so when we no longer use herbicide we
are in part eliminating this wild beam
will fight we'll have to find some
solution beneficial insects of course
he's up I couldn't resist
sorry for the eternal ladybug and it's
strawberry I always thought the walls in
the garden were there for the same heat
that's what everybody when I arrived in
this garden everyone told me that walls
are there to accumulate Heat I think the
walls are there to accumulate beneficial
insects and vertebrae that eat the ones
we don't want because I think in terms
of the heat it works it works even
better when you try to put the tomato
plants out in the middle of the garden
you put the tomato plants against the
wall even a north-facing wall you still
have healthier tomato plants I think has
to do with its environment
we even have a hawk that I thought like
got a picture of the other day so I had
to include it
I'm gonna go very quickly this is the
garden is inserted in the town on the
one we have one side this one side is
the park the three other sides are in
the city so if we use some kind of
general mean or a pyrethrum or when we
used to be a blight to use wrote notes
you're always blowing excuse my language
you're always blowing all the insects
away and we have no way of Cooper aiding
them other than within our own garden so
when you're in this kind of how to say
urban desert on one side or diversity
desert on the other you have to find
ways of creating diversity within the
garden itself this is the fruit a cedam
this theory that's where we have all the
different shrubs that's part of it it
looks a bit more unkempt than you can
imagine that site to generally be well
that's the garden I work in we've
included some within the fruit growing
areas we've included some non-productive
hedges and we can we really see the
difference between the side and it's not
proven scientifically I'd love someone
to come study it with us
we the impression the gardener's and I
have is that the side towards the shrub
towards the non-productive hedge is less
attacked than the one that's not and
we've had that same experience with our
prairies that we've sometimes replaced
the grass with because we've got sick of
mowing or rather the budget couldn't
deal with all the mowing in this case we
intervened three times in the year once
to prepare once to seed and wants to mow
as opposed to mowing every 12 days and
we do that in several places throughout
the garden this is my favorite current
experiment this is a picture from just
three weeks ago this is our I
transformed a space that was just below
the offices of the director of the
school that used to be a mall a lawn
okay and just below the windows of the
last year students into a permaculture
experiment and it's quite I shouldn't
say I the garden after working with some
of the students of the school and the
gardens this is how we transformed it
so we're working on it actually it's
based on a cubic quoi someone showed
nodding their head I'm trying remember
his name fall down there's a vegetable
producer just outside of Quebec who's
written a book in both French and
English that takes up on Elliot
Coleman's book and we're using some of
those techniques there le Pullman and
fault on using books from the middle of
the 19th century from Parisian gardeners
we even have some not just insects but
some geese and some chickens that help
out I call them dar there are gardeners
as well we have some sheep that we hope
they're not going to be shocked by this
that we regularly kill and barbecue
that's also part of educating in terms
of food it always gets me angry when
people only want they don't want to see
the carcass the angry is not the right
word disappoints me I think we really
have food education to be done I don't
think everyone should be the carnivorous
my companion is vegetarian it's not a
that just thinks about knowing where
things come from before making decision
this is my dream actually this is I'm
almost finished I've been pretty good
people often think we do exhibitions for
people to see outside I do exhibitions
for because I want the gardener's to see
what we're doing or where we should we
should be going I think we could
probably eliminate some of our tractors
we have small garden tractors with some
donkeys and I think we'll get there in
the next two or three years actually
because it's it's a different
relationship to the space it's a
different way of working and it's a
great way to try to make more people
come to this garden to see how we do it
don't forget it's about food
it's about gardeners it's in a wonderful
space and will always be a school thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu